at this point Netflix is an
entertainment staple and a full-fledged
cultural phenomenon and you may think
you have it all figured out but there
are plenty of tricks to help you take
your night in experience to the next
level
so get on in your couch group and
prepared to binge here are the Netflix
hacks you want to try ASAP category
codes Netflix is recommended categories
can get old pretty quickly and those old
fall backs just don't have to spark they
used to get familiar with subcategory
codes which give you access to more
specific films like drama starring Colin
Firth or Greek movies
there's a list seemingly a mile long so
you're essentially guaranteed to land on
something you'll love no matter how
obscure I decided I would use my new
super come through powers to fight crime
so became the best cup in the world
I became coach Curie highest-quality
we've all been there you're trying to
watch something on Netflix but the
quality keeps going out the window
last just it loses all meaning after
that well you may not be getting the
best out of your default Netflix
settings squeeze the best quality out of
your subscription by customizing your
playback settings to always stream in
high-definition
head into an account then my profile and
then playback settings here you have
some choices choose between auto which
is the default setting low for basic
video quality medium for standard
playback or high which plays all your
films and TV shows in crisp HD hotkeys
watching Netflix on your computer
Netflix has some built-in hotkeys to
make your viewing experience easier you
can press s to go full screen and hit
escape to return to normal
pressing enter or the spacebar will
allow you to pause and M needs the video
you can also rewind or fast-forward in
ten second increments by using the left
and right keys clear out continue
watching it's great to be able to go
back and finish shows and movies later
but that continue watching you can get
seriously bogged down over time
what are you ever going to finish
watching boyhood and that last season of
Dexter was weak fortunately it's easy to
keep your continue watching queue nice
and organized by getting rid of random
titles dive into account then my profile
and viewing activity to remove any shows
you've stopped watching click the tiny X
near each title you'd rather forget you
watched and Netflix will clear it from
the list allowing you to get back to the
things you're really interested in
that's a laser Reptar I thought the
wedding sink doesn't appears ago
kill all spoilers you know what's the
worst spoilers you're blazing through a
Twin Peaks or Breaking Bad when you
glance at the next episodes description
and suddenly making a murderer just got
a lot more literal fortunately you can
fight back with flicks plus a Google
Chrome extension that works with Netflix
to blur out any hidden spoilers in film
and TV show blurbs so sit back relax and
let your favorite characters do all the
killing spoiler free try new features
now flex is constantly developing
improvements and enhancements and
testing them in real time with real life
people take new features out for a spin
before anyone else by going to account
then settings and test participation
enrolling is as simple as shifting the
include me in tests and previews option
to on you may even get your hands on the
feature that changes Netflix forever
months before the general public does
control your account these days Netflix
accounts get passed around faster than
ear plugs at a Dave Matthews concert you
give your account login to a few friends
and suddenly you've lost track entirely
of everyone on your plan if you've had
multiple people using your Netflix
account in the past see who's still
benefiting from your monthly payment by
checking account then viewing activity
and clicking see recent account access
do things look strange is Aunt Gertrude
watching knitting wars out in Iowa again
take back the gift that keeps on giving
by signing out
all currently logged-in devices 4k
viewing we've all heard that beauty is
in the eye of the beholder
well netflix has taken note and started
introducing 4k titles to its library
under certain subscription plans if
you've got a 4k TV and a strong internet
connection and want to get the most out
of your hardware just type 4k into the
Netflix search box to browse Netflix's
Ultra HD library rating control you're
probably already aware the Netflix
caters and suggestions to you based on
your watch history play
can tell Netflix what you really want to
watch by going to account and then
ratings under the my profile section
here you can alter or remove ratings to
fine-tune your Netflix recommendations
watch offline we've all had a time when
we wanted to watch Netflix without an
internet connection maybe you're on a
long flight and itching to binge watch
some black mirror or you're out getting
in touch with nature but get bored with
the dumb flowers well you're in luck
there are a number of films and series
ready for download in Netflix's library
but this feature is only accessible on
ios and android devices all you have to
do is install the Netflix app on your
phone or tablet and when you log in
you'll be greeted with a download and go
splash page where you can tap find
something to download alternatively you
can make your way to the main menu where
you'll find the available for download
section tap the arrow button to save to
your device and you're all set for
offline viewing outside opinion next
time you're about to spend two hours on
a movie you're not sure about
check out Rotten Tomatoes first the
sights on DVD and streaming section
collects everything available on Netflix
plus a ton of other streaming services
so you can browse ratings to weed out
anything that's guaranteed to be awful
the site also has a list of new releases
hitting Netflix soon so you can always
pick a winner thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus to have all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]